so back in April rainbow succeed eSports
was having a bit of a panic attack NDA's
were broken pro league rosters were
dropped a couple different orgs left the
scene it was a mess and we reported on
it and now the pro player at the heart
of all of this has been banned from
everything Ubisoft related for an entire
year so let's break down what the hell
is going on here
[Music]
all right Before we jump into this crazy
story I need you guys to know that we're
streaming over on twitch.tv slash the
score eSports follow the channel
eventually you'll be able to sub and
you'll probably catch me slamming my
desk once again now let's get back into
it
okay so in April we reported a story
about the siege eSports community having
a pretty big meltdown your organization
tells you that at the end of this season
the entire roster is gonna be dropped
and the orga stepping back from CG
sports it was a crazy situation rosters
were dropped orgs backed out of the
scene and NDA's were broken and the guy
that set fire to a community looking for
something to be pissed off about was
this guy hyena and then this week months
after the initial shitstorm hyena
tweeted out that Ubisoft had banned him
from everything you saw fellated for an
entire year so what happened so you've
Asafa has been working on this new
version of pro-league that's set to kick
off sometime in June so pretty soon now
negotiations between Ubisoft and
luminosity gaming's involvement in this
new version of pro league broke down and
LG just left siege eSports entirely and
because of that LG told hyena and the
rest of the roster that they were being
dropped when the old version of pro
league ended on May 17th LG made a
meeting with us after likely confronted
them about some rumors we're hearing
they set up a meeting and they told us
that we're being released due to
negotiations falling through with you
stuff we said that oh is it true that
you guys had submit an application for
the pilot program he said that no that's
not true we just chose not to send it in
because you know we don't agree with how
sauce running it and they're not no
budging and negotiation so without and
then you know they said yeah you guys
we'll help you guys with the transition
period and this was all prior to the
like second split of pro league that
season so we still have like a you know
seven games to play
keep in mind nobody knew any of this
information yet just the players a
handful of LG management and of course
Ubisoft on top of that this all happens
right in the middle of the Koba 19
outbreak so the players were stuck in
their Las Vegas team house now this
situation fell under an NDA the players
signed along
their contracts so they weren't supposed
to talk about anything that they knew
which is why when hyena tweeted out
[ __ ] NDA parents didn't raise me like
that and exposed everything going on
behind the scenes the community exploded
this changed the course of our lives to
move out here and do this and for like
do Ubisoft and even LG to some extent to
just tell us like we have no new
information just sit tight and wait and
play the rest of the season not knowing
you're gonna have a spot like in the
next season after this one like it was
super stressful super discouraging you
know we all our motivation was at an
all-time low
we're like it completely kept in the
dark and like just the frustration just
kept building and building and building
you know and we were just messaging and
not getting anything but then this week
hyena tweeted out that he's been banned
from everything he was soft related for
an entire year and nobody knows why I
mean it I've looked into this story I've
talked to hyena I reached out to Ubisoft
who didn't get back to me it's a [ __ ]
mystery in the email that he received it
says that he's broken Ubisoft code of
conduct but no specific reason has been
given and in talking to hyena he thinks
that it's related to everything that
happened back in April now at this point
I think it's fair to say that hyena is
not completely innocent here frustrated
and pissed off about being dropped and
confused about what the future of his
career looks like he broke his NBA and
in his frustration he didn't handle the
limited communication he did have with
Ubisoft very well we need information
like this is getting ridiculous and I
sure if I just told it like this is
unacceptable like you are either tell us
to tell me something or I'm gonna just
go public with all of this look I get it
this dude broke an NDA Ubisoft can't
just let that slide if that's what this
ban is for again we don't know but in
his own words his r6 career is pretty
much over at this point and this
punishment seems unnecessarily harsh to
be honest it's a pretty strange end to a
story that doesn't really feel over and
hopefully you basalt gives an update to
hyenas ban at some point soon now this
whole mess started because hyena broken
NDA related to yubi sauce new Pro League
which is set to kick off in June at some
point
well we still have a ton of questions
about this new pro league let's go over
what we do know first so we know that
pro league is broken down into four
regions with 52 teams competing and a
pro league has 8 teams down from the 10
they were expecting and of those 8 2 are
brand new to siege eSports we also know
that this new pro league will be an
offline LAN League based in Vegas and
pro leagues weird cousin here in Canada
is getting its own version with 4 teams
competing offline while another 16
battle online in a challenge early we
know that you saw planned for 2 majors
this year plus s eye but with ongoing
Kovac concerns those plans are currently
up in the air you soft also announced a
bunch of changes to the competitive
format and released a road map as to
what seed should look like over the next
few years the four independent regional
leaves run from March to December these
leagues are divided into three stages at
the end of each stage the top four teams
from each region will qualify for the
six major a global competition featuring
the top 16 international teams now we
haven't heard anything about the rumored
tiered structure of this league
apparently it relates to how much money
the orgs make off of things like team
skins and how much developer support
they get from what I've heard it's
broken into three with Tier one getting
the most amount of everything
think of orgs like Space Station gaming
g2 or other big legacy teams and on the
opposite end is tier 3 which gets the
[ __ ] end of the stick and it's rumored
that teams starting in tier 3 will be
incentivized to work their way up to
tier 1 but we have no idea what those
incentives look like right now but you
got to assume that doing well
competitively is probably gonna be a big
part of it the last big thing that siege
is waiting on has to do with the game
itself over the last few months the
community has been pretty vocal but the
gameplay problems siege is dealing with
rampant cheating and unbalanced meta
that's not fun to play the list goes on
I'm pretty sure that is DDoS the server
in late May Ubisoft released a blog post
that when it comes to cheating doesn't
really say much it promises more updates
in year 5 season 2 which again is coming
out at some
in June and then on June first we got a
small update to the season 2 test server
which fixed a few problems with new
operators but left a bunch of
frustrating issues with the meta
untouched so we'll probably see a much
bigger patch when season two's steel
wave actually launches siege isn't a bit
of a mess right now with the question
still surrounding pro-league the
gameplay problems this hyena Fiasco it's
a weird time to be a siege fan but
honestly I'm optimistic that Ubisoft can
figure it out and that siege will be
back on top in no time I would like to
just own one just cuz like a straight
jacket I feel like it'd be a cool
collectible to have you know this is my
bowling ball this is my straight jacket
yeah I stole it back in college I stole
a bowling ball so I got super-drunk and
put it in my bag and then stole the
bowling ball we were rolling it around
the subway I'm like 1:00 in the morning
and then I woke up in my bed and this
[ __ ] bowling ball was like digging
into my side